[Music]
all right
shimon thank you for being with us hi
it's awesome to be here thank you very
much for having me
all right so um at eight
you disassembled the computer you became
this this computer wiz
went on to iron source now founder of
the co-founder of a company
and you did beauty and the geek which
i'm a big fan of but
we'll put that for another time what
happened
at the age of eight wha what's what's
going on
the age of eight so
i remember this is my first encounter
with the computer you know i woke up
and it's after my parents they brought a
computer home and i woke up
and i saw this thing i was like what is
this and i clicked the buttons to turn
it on
and like i didn't know that i need to
turn on the screen
like nothing happened so i didn't
understand why so i like
okay so i unplugged it and opened the
computer to look at what's inside
and to start to understand what's going
on that was my first encounter with
who does that i'm 24 and i still don't
do that i was asked to do it and i still
and i didn't want to do it well
no i love it i love it but i think you
know the the moment that the
i'm the most proud and the most ashamed
of is when i was 13
i i learned about this thing called
linux and i was really fascinated about
it so i really i downloaded it was red
hat 6
i burned the iso and i was like that's
it i installed linux on my computer and
i was so
fascinated by it and then i ran to the
living room and i tell my mother
i'm startling rocks i start linux and
she was like
yeah yeah it will be okay we'll find a
keyword
no problem
okay so then okay so let's move forward
and you go to iron source and you're
managing
what are you what do you do there you're
doing something with 400 engineers the
whole infrastructure
yeah so iron source is a large media
company
today it's around 900 million dollar arr
and i joined when we were 30 people
and i left when the company was 800 and
i was the general manager of the
engineering infrastructure division
so responsible for all of the cross
company engineering
cicd internal tools data collection data
pipelining
in it's all of the infrastructure for
the developers
and okay so honestly what's it like
managing
a devops infrastructure for 400 people i
had to do it
you know in the army for 12 people and i
don't think i did a very good job at it
and so i can't even begin to imagine how
you how you can begin to think about an
organization that has 400 people in it
yeah so i think that iron source was
exceptionally well
and good in terms of which people it
hired the culture was very good
but at the end of the day it's really
really hard just to you know collaborate
400 people
and as the company scale you know you
start with those
tribal knowledge we usually do that we
usually do that
why did you use this package we use the
other one and then as you scale
to be bigger and bigger and bigger and
every day there's a new engineer being
hired
it starts to be un you know
unmaintainable and i remember
this one time a developer accidentally
or not accidentally i think he just
didn't know committed
his aws secret keys into a public github
repository
and we got hacked and we were very very
lucky
because the hack was only automated
bitcoin miners
that spin up on all the aws regions
so we were like okay and then the ceo
was like okay shimon you run of all of
our infrastructure engineering so let's
make sure this does not happen again
and then i was faced with the question
so how do you
align 400 engineers so i was very naive
i sent them an email i wrote it in the
wiki
i you know i did a meetup i did a
webinar but you know
it doesn't really work it doesn't scale
so what do companies do i mean you have
to align you know
google has dozens of thousands of
engineers i mean
not just google so many other companies
already have thousands of engineers
how do you align based and the another
problem is that you know when an
engineer moves from company to company
there are different practices
and you know i'm now i just did an
onboarding as a software engineer at
hippo and
and i had to really study what their
conventions are how do they handle the
repositories what do i upload what do i
not upload
that's not even talking about how the
code should be written
so now that you have this experience how
do you deal with that
so what we see today is you know
let's talk about like what what happened
why is this so important now and what
was so unique about my previous company
the company was born in the cloud and
it was born working in agile so today
many companies
if if they're a more traditional company
they they felt that they're too rigid
and if they're a new company they
started from the get-go
being agile so companies switched from
waterfall into agile development
so they gave freedom to developers then
together with that
companies are moving from monolith into
a microservices or starting in a service
oriented architecture
which also brings a challenge by itself
because you now have dozens and hundreds
and some of our customers have
thousands of git repositories and
each one of them might have its own
programming language
its own structured files like docker
file kubernetes file clcd file
and it's like a whole universe inside a
git repository and now you have 500 of
those
and you need to collaborate between them
and thirdly
is that today companies um
give developer autonomy so it's no
longer the days
in many organizations where you know
back in the day we used to write code as
developers
drink our coffee give it to some devops
person
operations person then they they will
inspect it for one month and deploy to
the cloud
and the developers would you know come
to work no today you have
developer autonomy developers write the
code test it build it deploy it wake up
and four in the morning if there's a
problem
and the cross infrastructure teams
devops teams security teams
they can't keep up with the rate of
change
so they need to inspect every pull
request
it you can't do it so they rely on on
you know on automation
and on tools to help them do that
and in many cases companies either try
to build their own unmaintainable
you know versions of the tree or like
things to help solve that
um or they try to do it manually
you know and hope developers remember
but obviously it doesn't scale
and once they have an incident they just
start putting on more and more
procedures um and hopefully automating
um i believe in automation so
so so you so one of the things that
dramatically changed over the past
dozen years or so is the role of a
developer right so now i
enter a company i'm no longer
responsible for just
learning the language i'm assigned to
and how to write logic in it but i need
to know
how does continuous integration work how
to do proper code reviews
how to format my code so that it matches
others
and are so on one hand it seems like
developers are given more autonomy to
express
their creativity and their their power
on the other hand
they need to be more than ever we need
to be aligned
to a common structure is that is that
conflicting
those two ideas absolutely absolutely
you know
there are some companies they have holy
wars you know tabs and spaces it's a
it's a funny example but a proud we're a
proud species right we
yeah i think that um this is one thing
but
what i see in most companies is that
it's just
hard to propagate the development
standard even if you have one at the end
of the day it's important to have one
and to stick with it
and to change it if needed but in many
cases you know
poor bob doesn't be the person who takes
production down
sally doesn't want to be the developer
who actually commits secrets right she
doesn't want to be
this person and you know that
brings a security hazard to the
organization but in many cases they
don't know
and this is why i believe that
automation is the key and being
integrated within the developer workflow
and providing a shift left solution
that as you write the code as you open
up a pull request
you see what am i doing wrong what
should i do
because it should be easy to do the
right thing like
if you if you disagree with some policy
if you want to change a standard that's
absolutely fine you should have a
discussion you should you know talk
about it
that's great but in most cases people
just don't know
and they make mistakes because they have
no way of knowing
so shimano i mean you're one of the best
entrepreneurs that i know
and you you look to make an impact i
know you and
you always think about how do i make a
large scale impact and you have a
startup
in the devops space you just finished y
combinator how was that experience by
the way
that was amazing wow and i really
recommend it
yeah i mean if you can get in right mean
it's crazy
not even anybody can do it it's amazing
that you did it
yeah i'm very like before we went we
also talked to other companies
and and everyone really recommended it
our company was a bit far along
than other companies but it actually
helped us because actually i met michael
seibel the ceo of y combinator in israel
and i told him like what we do is we
help engineering teams enforce their
development standards and security
policies
directly within the developer's workflow
so it goes like
so this is applicable to like 95 percent
of yc companies i'm like yeah
it's like like okay so we applied and
we got it no i have to say i've been
reading some of
the some of and recent horror and
dressing's um
mark andreessen's articles recently and
you know all he talks about is how
software is eating the world
and and and he starts talking about this
recently
which is a discussion that's different
from 10 years ago i don't think 10 years
ago people
talked about workflows and and and
structure
so so a little bit about what what is
that tree what are you doing
and i'm curious to hear how how can you
measure an impact of this on a large
scale because
you know when somebody builds a company
that's i don't know trying to
trying to find a vaccine for corona you
can yes you can say yeah the impact i'm
creating is
saving is saving people it's very direct
now your impact is a little indirect by
helping a lot of other companies make an
impact so i'd love to i'd love to hear
your thought process on that yeah so you
know
it's like what is the impact of gmail i
think it's huge
do they create a corona vaccine no but i
think their impact is huge right
um oh they're allowing others to create
scene by
communicating exactly so i'll tell you
what i think and answer would be a
little bit
devopsy in the field but i wasn't
thinking less
but like if you think of of of where
we're at
i believe that the solution like the
tree is required and every company will
have it
and i'll give you the following argument
let's say 10 years ago i would have told
you
listen um i'm gonna provide you a
service that's gonna take your code
compile it test it and ship it to a
server
you're gonna say what are you crazy i'm
just making a zip file and
scp-ing it to my server why do i need
this and today everyone knows you need a
ci cd solution
yeah so the same thing is happening here
i'm
positively sure that every company is
going to need to have a solution like
the tree
to take a hold of all of those
distributed systems
to make sure that they can move fast and
execute at great speed
while having operational consistency and
having a security posture to be able to
collaborate and move fast
because otherwise every time we're going
to be stopping and stopping and stopping
and not working at the velocity
that we want to achieve yeah and this is
what i believe is going to happen
i mean you know when zuckerberg changed
uh facebook used to be
known as move fast and break things and
it changed a little bit
uh in recent years so i think that and
that's the reason why right because when
you grow
at scale and you want to maintain that
velocity you're also
sacrificing some of the quality and you
start breaking
too many quality things so so what is so
the trees just is really a platform
where you can enforce company policies
for best practices
on on git repositories and code base
right
yeah so think about it like at the
higher level
is implementing your development
standards and security policies yeah
some use cases include
can be security make sure you don't
commit secrets
make sure that any research that you're
creating in s3 with cloudformation for
example
is encrypted um make sure that all of
your developers are following stock 2
development practices
or hipaa and the way the solution works
we
we hook on top of your source control so
you install us as a
for example github application we scan
your entire source control
extract the metadata from all of your
structured files all the yaml json
xml docker files and then we recommend
the development practices and security
policies
for your technology stack so if we
detect that using docker or kubernetes
or serverless
we're going to recommend the practices
for you so gonna save time
from researching what is the right thing
to do you can just say okay
don't run containers just use the root
don't pull containers with the latest
tag
put a pin down version and it's sort of
like a devops database of policies
that you can automatically take those
best practices and apply them
in your organization and this will help
you
but you know you're i mean all these
companies already have you know millions
of lines of code i think
nasa is one of those working with you
right
so how do you go how do you go to
company like that and say
let's now rethink how we're organizing
our
our policy structure how do you how do
you even go about that
so we don't do that so what we do is we
say okay
listen up so number one you need
visibility
you need to know what is going on you
have problems everyone knows they have
problems so
just install our github application will
scan your entire source control
and you will see the report of what is
going on like nasa is
installed on their open source it's like
public knowledge so i can say
and so you can see what is going on now
maybe there is a certificate in there
maybe there are commits by admin at
macbook pro
who you have no idea who it is and when
an auditor will tell you to get
blame you will see that it's committed
from admin at macbook pro and you have
no idea who that is
number one visibility see what you have
number two
prevent problems from happening in the
future you you don't need to take a
three months process of thinking
what no peop there are some things
people know all
assets should be encrypted in motion and
address so make sure every cloud
formation has that
um every a pull request needs to have a
jira ticket in the pure request title
because we're stuck to
no problem so you can start by that and
then we have a curated list of rules
that you can choose and pick from
and of course it's also everything is
customizable so you can define
your custom rules so start small and
expand
yeah i mean it makes a lot of sense
you're coming in and you're saying let's
let's
i can think of it you're going to a big
company let's start with the small team
let's show that it works
and i'm guessing just by word of mouth
and by experience the next
project that they start will include
that and then one of the developers
switches teams
and they say hey let's use the tree also
here
is that is that a model that you think
could allow you to
sort of enter these bigger companies
yeah so this is not
exactly what we're seeing so what is
happening is that usually our champion
is like
someone who's like devops or
infrastructure
those type of people you need by the way
github administrator access
so when i say by start small i mean
start with a small amount of policies
but usually they apply them across a lot
of repositories
okay so they take things that are like
no-brainer like don't commit
i don't know certificates right and then
apply it across everything and then
curate other rules that you want and you
can apply them on some
substance substances of your um
repositories yeah now in terms of land
and spread i agree with you but it's
more of like a
department by department not like small
team by small team
or the entire organization all at once
so so
where's the tree heading what's it gonna
be like in three four years
so i believe we're going to be in the
workflow of
many of the if not all of the best
companies today right everyone's gonna
rely
on the tree to number one help with
visibility see what you have
number two help with governance to
prevent bad things from happening
but number three and it's something that
we already have some features around
is remediation and automation i know
that
you have a problem you did not run a
certain set of tests or
maybe your settings are incorrect let us
remediate
and fix it for you or let us suggest a
fix
that you can just automatically apply so
this is the the way we're headed at
so once it develops always it develops
no because it's incredible because i
mean you love do you love doing things
and oftentimes you would think of
somebody who's a devops
as as a different on a different place
than an engineer but
honestly you're you're one of the best
engineers that i know and i think it's
just really awesome to see how you're
you're you're
on you worked at iron source you managed
this problem and you
said okay i mean everybody in the world
has this and
i honestly i it sounds like you just
have the perfect timing because it
sounds like if you came up with this 10
years ago
just when ciacd was barely starting it
would have been meh
two years down the line there's probably
going to be three competitors who are
working on this
uh so i think you really got the sweet
spot before
before i let you go back to running your
company i need three words that describe
you
determine the reaction i get determined
passionate
in a determinant passionate and i'd say
um um
i'm also pretty sensitive
i love it i love it okay shimon next
time we're talking about beauty and the
geek
okay simon thank you so much
it's great thank you very much for
having me it's always great to have you
bye
you